Florida Republican Governor Ron DeSantis
had both endorsedes lose on Tuesday and
of course the failed former and wannabe
future president Donald Trump is trying
to capitalize on this the truth is
Trump's trothing aside
the truth is that Ron DeSantis is not
only
increasingly low in the polling
he is also visibly losing notably losing
political Capital as two endorsees have
lost let's look at exactly what happened
the hill reporting DeSantis sees both
endorsed candidates lose DeSantis
stepped into the Kentucky Republican
gubernatorial primary to back former U.N
Ambassador Kelly Kraft endorsing Craft
on Election Day a little bit late in the
game as polling in the run-up to the
election projected Kraft lost to
attorney general Daniel Cameron
Trump backed Cameron
whatever you believe about Trump's
endorsement record and it's quite
mediocre overall this is very clearly a
public win for Trump
um the other example of course is uh
what was the other example I actually
don't have it here uh who else did did
uh to say I don't know oh uh oh I see
here Democrats flip mayor's office
Republican uh Daniel Davis succeeds
mayor Lenny Curry DeSantis backed Davis
but Curry won there as well so Trump
immediately seizes on this as I would be
doing as well because this just looks
very bad for DeSantis Trump posting to
his platform truth Central quote wow in
a big upset the de sanctimonious-backed
Republican candidate for mayor of
Jacksonville Florida lost this is a
shocker
if they would have asked me to capital E
endorse he would have won easily Too
Proud to do so fools this is a big loss
for the Republican party remember Rob
only won because of me he now calls Ron
DeSantis Rob then continuing to post
truths quote de sanctimonious lost
Jacksonville and Kentucky last night not
good and then lastly quote
congratulations to a quote star in
Kentucky Daniel Cameron who easily won
the Republican nomination for governor
he had my Capital C complete and total
endorsement the de sanctimonious backed
candidate came in a distant third Ron's
magic is gone he also lost shockingly in
Jacksonville last night mayor and the
truth is you know Trump lies all the
time
but Trump is rightly assessing that
desantises I I was going to call it a
campaign but it's not yet really a
campaign desantises would be campaign is
in complete and total free fall I
reported to you yesterday that DeSantis
polling had collapsed all the way down
to just over 20 percent in the
Republican primary and overnight
DeSantis is now below 20 percent
just barely at 19.9 and as I've said
before with Trump surging now at 56.
remember a few weeks ago Trump was at
43. if Trump's at 43 you look at that
and you say hey if I just get the
non-trump vote if Trump has 43 there's
57 out there available if I can get that
I can win the primary without taking a
single vote from Trump
now is all the way up to 56 percent
when Trump is at 56 percent you now have
to contend with the reality that if you
scoop up somehow all of the non-trump
vote
you only have 44 and so then you have to
justify how can I take votes from Trump
and I don't know how DeSantis does it
that's where we are right now the
DeSantis campaign truly in free fall
that being said interestingly the
reports are that DeSantis still plans to
announce a candidacy and as I've said
before
I can see both sides on the one hand I
don't see what the Santa's path to
Victory is right now on the other hand
if you're DeSantis and you have sick
offense around you as many of these
people often do you might be saying to
yourself the fact that I even have 19.9
and I haven't announced tells me this
may be my shot
sure I could wait until 2028 when I
guess the sandus would be 48 years old I
could do that
but anything could happen between now
and then my I might be trying with five
percent in 2028 I have 20 right now
maybe Trump gets indicted again or again
or again gets arrested a couple more
times it pulls him off the campaign
Trail Anything could happen maybe I need
to be there sort of like the Seinfeld
episode where I think it was Jerry who
says listen I'm just going to be there
for her
after some kind of a breakup and then
I'll just be there and who knows if
she's interested then I'll just be there
this may be quite frankly DeSantis
approach I only have 20 percent
I don't know how I'll take supporters
from Trump but if things go wrong I will
just be there I don't think it looks
good for DeSantis reports are he may
announce within the next seven to ten
days we will watch it one uh quick
reminder Monday Memorial Day we are
doing a one day membership special the
goal is to kick start membership
uh and we will be doing it with an
incredible discount code if you'd like
to be notified of how to take advantage
of this membership special on Monday
morning Memorial Day all you have to do
is get on my mailing list at
davidpakman.com
one of our sponsors is zipx nicotine
toothpicks don't you think it's time you
stopped putting smoke and vape oils in
your lungs zippix toothpicks are a
convenient way to curb the nicotine
Cravings zipx toothpicks are super
discreet you can use them anytime
anywhere smoking and vaping aren't
allowed including flights sporting
events in restaurants they're available
in six different flavors with options of
two and three milligrams of nicotine if
you're not a nicotine user zipix also
offers caffeine and b12 infused
toothpicks zipx has already helped tens
of thousands of customers ditch the
cigarettes ditch the Vapes they might be
able to help you too if you're a smoker
or a vapor give zipx toothpicks a try
your lungs will thank you go to
zipxtoothpix.com today save 10 with the
code pacman10 at checkout out just
remember you must be 21 or older to
order the link is down below